hallo mein name ist luca um meine lieben
freunde wir schauen uns heute gemeinsam
13 tipps an wie du eine attacke von
einem wilden tier überlebst haie
verursachen nur sechster wurde pro jahr
ihr berüchtigter ruf ist also sehr
übertrieben wort wölfe sind für zehn
tote pro jahr verantwortlich löwen töten
22 menschen pro jahr erwartet wahrheit
nur 6
das halte ich fest elefanten die
liebenswürdigen giganten sind die
todesursache für mehr als 500 menschen
pro jahr
alles klar als die pferde sind in diesem
furchterregenden wettbewerb gleichauf
mit ihnen was die motive sind
tatsächlich viel gefährlicher als hype
ungefähr 1000 tode im jahr ok absoluter
spitzenreiter ist aber die schlange
100.000 menschen sterben pro jahr und
eines schlangenbissen
sandra ich schwöre bei gott als ich habe
immer schon gesagt dass diese dreckigen
mister einfach nur ohne dich auf dieser
scheiß geilen welt sind diese kennen
miststück nummer 13 okay die gute
nachricht ist dass von den 150 auf der
erde existierenden hai arten nur 20
menschen attackieren ach so ich
dachte alle haie sind gefährlich wenn
sich ein hai einmal für dich
interessiert dann wirst du ihn kaum los
ob das dürfen keine haie anzulocken darf
mit urin oder blut ins wasser gelangt
sein mehr haie können die gerüche über
mehrere kilometer entfernung riesen
kilometer
das sind
das sind 1000 meter graf in das tier
ganz nah ist dann kehre dem raubtier
nicht den rücken zu ok und versuche
keinesfalls panisch zu flüchten ok so
siehst du wie eine beute aus bewege dich
langsam
[Musik]
wird sie sich gerade ein pokémon oder so
der tipp ist bullshit oder der heim-em
ist es doch wirklich glaube ich scheiß
egal ob ich mich bewegt oder nicht da
denkt doch mal ein schnitzel bewegt sich
dabei sich jetzt recht zu nummer 12
kangaroos
kängurus
weil er steht schon ein känguru kann
gefährlich werden aber wir müssen noch
nicht gefährlich oder ja überraschender
weise kann ein känguru gefährlich werden
das passiert aber nur wenn du in seinem
territorium eindringen und das tier sich
bedroht fühlt aber in can roca dann doch
nichts antun oder obwohl die haben schon
krass wenn muskeln musste seinen husten
sind für das känguru ein zeichen für
krankheit und es wird sich
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht angreift was
was
ist wenn das känguru sich dann so sagt
oder hustet und hat keine maske auf
bottin greife jetzt sichern kommen
bediene mich in meinem territorium was
und das würden bullshit weiche langsam
zurück auf diese weise siehst du kleiner
aus und damit weniger bedrohlich also
wenn irgendein känguru bald stress
machen sollte bei euch einfach husten
und sich entfernt
nummer 1 trifft auf einen löwen dann
halte augenkontakt
dre ihnen nicht den rücken zu und denken
nicht seine augen ansonsten greift das
raubtier an ok
der loewe sieht vor 2000 über zehn
elefanten elefanten sind so fanden sind
schlau und ziemlich freundliche tiere er
aber sie sind bekannt dafür dass die
menschen angreifen wusste ich auch nicht
das trifft vor allem auf weibliche
elefanten mit dazu
[Musik]
weibliche elefanten greifen männer
sind männliche nicht also von wegen ruhe
lassen ein weibchen in rohr oder
irgendwie so wenn du einen elefanten
trifft dann achte auf seine
körpersprache ok hat er einen
aufgerollten rüssel und die ohren hinten
angelegt dann bitte auf dich losrennen
aufgerollte rüssel und ohren angelehnt
gegen den stetigkeit oder nähert sich
der elefant dann rennen nicht weg ok
wegen dich hinter einem hindernis
zwischen dir und dem tierschutz es kann
ein stein oder ein baum sein ja was wenn
ich auf einer wiese bin
obwohl er gut ich die tour ist ganz so
als ob ich jeden tag elefanten kängurus
löwen und schlagen geklickt wird nummer
9 nashörner er saß hören oder sehen
schlecht deshalb kann man sie leicht
verstecken würden was sie zu einer
attacke provozieren dieses tier kann bis
zu 60 kilometer pro stunde schnell
rennen
ich frage nix mehr der einzige weg von
einem nachbarn zu flüchten ist sich
hinter einem baum zu verstecken
der einzige weg
ja warte wenn mich nass an angreift ich
eher see kurz ein paar samen und warte
bis ein baum wächst immer acht pferde
sind auch so süße tiere trotz ihres
gewichts können sie mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 30 kilometer pro
stunde rennen geisteskranke haben eher
einen launischen charakter das ist sehr
einfach ist sie zu verärgern
[Musik]
wenn ihr fell muss man bestimmt irgendwo
hoch klettern dann vermeidet es bei
hitze die büsche zu betreten okay das
wasser level sinkt während der dürre und
die nilpferde verstecken sich dann im
hohen gras ok in vor ihnen zu pflichten
kannst du auf einen baum fällt oder
einen steilen hügel pflichten
ich denke mir immer so ja ok cool aber
wie kommt man denn da weg
ob ich jetzt im meer abend mit einem hey
da muss ich trotzdem wieder wegschwimmen
und mich bewegen oder hier auf einem
baum dann muss ich wieder runter der
welcher trotz mit höchst nummer sieben
stiere stiere war es gegen der
verbreiteten annahme reagieren stehe auf
bewegungen und nicht auf die farbe rot
oder irgendeine andere farbe okay
deshalb solltest du gerade und stellt
dastehen wenn ein stier optisch rennt
das werde ich niemals können
es ist in der natur des menschen
verankert das werden sich gefahr dass
man vor der gefahr flüchtet punkt also
wer da die eier besitzt wenn ein stier
begegne ich weiß ja wo stiere leben
alter in düsseldorf nummer sechs qualen
ekelhaft einen qualm stich verursacht
einen lang anhaltenden starken schmerz
ich hab noch nie in quallen stich
einfach manche glauben dass es hilft
darauf zu urinieren aber das ist nur ein
gerücht was
letzte was ein kollege bei mir machen
würde so auf mich drauf passen branche
den stich sofort mit salzwasser ab
normales trinkwasser wird der schmerz
nur verschlimmern weil du bist ja eh
mehr und da ist er logischerweise
salzwasser nummer fünf alligatoren oder
krokodile wurdest du gefasst dann
schlage auf die augen die augen und der
heißt die satire sind am empfindlichsten
wie soll ich den wir auch dahin kommen
[Gelächter]
wenn du merkst du hast hier nähert dann
machen so viel lärm wie möglich und
rennen im zickzack in diesem fall ist es
genau richtig zu rennen und schreien ist
die beste lösung warum
soll ich das krokodil so denkt armen und
und wieder schreit die ganze zeit wenn
er was zu essen sieht nummer vier
schlangen meisten schlangen sind weder
gefährlich noch geflickt ja in 80
prozent der fälle werden menschen
gebissen wenn sie versuchen die schlange
zu fangen ja du merkst du dass eine
schlange die folgt dann stampfe auf den
boden
nummer 3 während ein wildtier wird ihr
aus instinkt folgen und wenn du denkst
hast vor einem jahr davon rennen kannst
kann vergiss es sie können eine
geschwindigkeit von 48 kilometer pro
stunde erreichen
wo man ja so viel psd lege dich auf den
boden und räumlich 1 entdecke deinen
nacken mit seinen händen
also so hinlegen und einrollen
damit es einfacher für den bären es mich
zu essen nummer zwei gorillas werden
nicht umsonst als die könige des
dschungels bezeichnet werden die das
hier sind anführer die ihre familie und
ihr land beschützen dabei ist dass die
fans dann
sorry aber wenn ich corrida wer will ich
ihn einfach aus prinzip töten setz dich
hin damit du nicht größer als der
gorilla aussiehst versorgt zu flüstern
und vermeide direkten augenkontakt also
ein bisschen so wie mogli so tun als
wenn man ein kleinkind ankommen und
sagen du bist der beste nummer eins
bienen bienen die ihnen schützen ihren
bienenstock sie können zu stechen wenn
du nur vorbei läuft ja zuallererst will
ich erstmal die augen zumachen müssen
dunkle farben ziehen bienen an wenn du
also ein schwarzes t shirt trägt ist das
risiko von ihnen gestochen zu werden
viel höher
krass wenn ein schwarm oder mehrere
bienen hier folgen dann mir folgt
niemand schwarm tritt schon lange
aufgegeben verstecke dich an einem
dunklen ort die fehlende beleuchtung
macht es ihnen unmöglich zu verfolgen
auch bienen gucken nicht so gut oder wie
brille fielmann an erzählt euch das
heutige videos allerdings ob er denn
meine lieben freunde ich erwarte von
euch ein riesiges dankeschön luca unten
in den kommentaren denn wenn ihr gleich
draußen vor die tür geht und aus einer
pfütze springt plötzlich ein krokodil
raus ihr lauft weg in den busch
versteckt euch da der haupt nilpferd
dann springt er aus dem bus heraus oder
guckt ihr auf dem baum hoch unter sitzen
gorilla und springt auf euch runter dann
könnt ihr mir nämlich danken und das
könnte auch ganz einfach machen indem in
dem video einen daumen hoch gibt beim
kanal abonniert und auf die glocke
klickt damit ihr weitere videos nicht
verpasst wir sehen uns im dschungel
tschüss